I cut down that pad is clear
nine eight I want to try to sequence has
started six five four three two one go
for launching
vehicle is supersonic
stage separation confirmed Dragon
separation confirmed
[Music]
stage one is Trans on it Landing
Lakeside deployed
and Falcon 9 has landed
you are looking at a live view of the
Falcon 9 set to lift off at 11 48 PM
Pacific time from space launch complex 4
East at Vandenberg space Force Base
hello everyone and thank you for tuning
in I'm Jesse Anderson I'm joining you
from SpaceX headquarters in Hawthorne
California just a few hours south of our
launch site tonight we are launching
spacex's transporter 7 Mission this is
our seventh dedicated small sat
Rideshare program launch this Mission
will Mark our 24th launch for this year
and 224th mission of all time
now on this flight our 51 spacecraft
including cubesats microsats hosted
payloads and orbital transfer Vehicles
carrying spacecraft to be deployed at a
later time
now it might be worth mentioning that
weather is currently red for liftoff at
this time but moving forward with our t0
of 11 48 PM Pacific time to see if we
can find some good weather
now there will be a total of 36
deployments made between two deployment
sequences the first deployment sequence
will begin around the t plus one hour
mark and will last for approximately 20
minutes
we are expecting to lose ground station
coverage part way through the first
deployment sequence so only some of our
deployments will be visible today
however when we gain coverage or ground
station coverage we do expect to have
Telemetry and hear audio confirmation
over the Nets
the second and last deployments will
happen at the T plus 2 hour and 35
minute Mark after additional second
stage Burns
and speaking of payloads on board the
Falcon 9 today we have a main payload
located at the top of the stack for our
customer
the Imagine spacecraft is the fourth
satellite manufactured by tubitaku zai
which is the space Branch for the
scientific and technological research
Council of turkey imagine in Turkish
means collaboration or Collective work
as it was a project that was worked on
by several institutions and holds great
significance in the Turkish culture and
with that here's a video highlighting
our main payload
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hey everyone I'm Sarah vastava a
structures engineer here at SpaceX on
your screen is a live view of the Falcon
9 which is a reusable two-stage rocket
which rolled out to the pad and went
vertical early this morning
Falcon 9 is kind of like two rockets in
one with the first stage and the second
stage stacked on top of one another a
rocket can be defined as the engine or
the m1d rocket engine or the vehicle
which is propelled by the engine in this
case the Falcon 9 rocket for a sense of
scale the two scale the two-stage Falcon
9 stands about 70 meters tall which is
slightly taller than a 21-story building
what you're seeing on your screen are
the four main parts that make up the
rocket the first and second stages the
black composite inner stage which
connects those two
and the payload fairing at the very top
speaking of the fairing the 51
spacecraft on board the second stage
today are safely enclosed inside the
large pointed structure at the very top
of the rocket which is the payload
fairing it's it's right until it started
to protect them until the vehicle is
outside of the Earth's atmosphere at
which point the two fairing halves
separate to expose them to the vacuum of
space
right below the fairing we have our
second stage which houses our single
Merlin vacuum engine or the mvac engine
which will Propel our payloads to their
eventual destination in space
on today's Mission you might notice
something a bit different which is that
we are flying with a shorter nozzle
extension attached to our m-back engine
going forward our teams plan to use this
shorter nozzle when we don't need as
much performance to get the payload to
its final destination
stage one rp1 load complete but don't
worry the larger nozzles are not going
away forever and we still plan to fly
the full stage the full-sized mvac
nozzles on missions that require a more
significant amount of thrust from stage
two or ones that contain a heavier
payload so keep an eye out for that
after stage separation
moving on further down the rocket below
the second stage is the black carbon
fiber interstage the inner stage
connects the two stages and houses the
center Pusher that allows the first and
second stages to separate during flight
it also houses the M back nozzle which I
was just talking about
and below that we have the first stage
which we usually refer to as the booster
the first stage makes up the bottom
two-thirds of the vehicle and has nine
m1d engines at the bottom those nine
Merlin engines do the bulk of the work
to get Falcon 9 off the ground and up to
the thinner parts of the Earth's
atmosphere
stage one is the primary part of Falcon
9 that we recover refurbish and reuse
for multiple flights which allows us to
bring down the cost of regularly
launching Rockets
at around two and a half minutes into
flight the first stage will separate and
make its way back to Earth to attempt a
land landing at Landing Zone 4 which
isn't too far from the launch pad
for those of you who are keeping track
today's Mission marks the 10th flight
for this particular booster which has
previously supported the Sentinel 6
Michael freilich Mission Dart and seven
Starling commissions
for today's Mission unlike typical
Falcon 9 missions we'll be performing a
single engine entry burn and a
three-engine landing burn on the first
stage after stage separation
this is due to the change of second
stage engine performance with the
shorter nozzle so switching out the
number of engines we light up during
these two Milestones on the booster
during descent will allow us to more
efficiently land on lz4
we've previously performed similar types
of burns most commonly on the Falcon
heavy side boosters
this will however be the first Falcon 9
first stage to perform these burns with
this changed engine configuration to
land back on land
it's also worth noting that we are
predicting slightly higher winds during
our Landing attempt but hopefully the
weather will cooperate with us
so be sure to keep an eye out during
both entry and Landing burn to see if
you can see the difference based on how
many engines are lit up
at T-minus 3 minutes and 33 seconds the
vehicle is healthy and we are currently
tracking no issues however the currently
the weather is currently a watch item
and red but we are planning on moving
towards our planned t0 of 11 48 PM if
for some reason we do not launch today
we have another opportunity tomorrow at
the same time
stage one lock load complete
our goal with these missions is to
provide small satellite operators
competitive pricing increased flight
opportunities and flexibility we're
flying some really cool payloads on this
Mission including several different
types of Earth observation spacecraft
collecting greenhouse gas emissions data
hyperspectral Imaging student research
projects and orbit changing Vehicles
it's pretty incredible how even the
smallest satellites can make meaningful
contributions to take care of the of
planet Earth and our efforts to visit
other worlds and we're looking forward
to providing a great ride to space for
these 51 payloads on board today in just
a few minutes from now
now at this point we have completed
locks loading on the first stage
we're coming up a lot coming up on locks
loading completion on the second stage
in a few seconds here at the T-minus two
minute Mark and again we are keeping our
eye on the weather 420.
stage two left flow complete there's
that call out that we were waiting for
liquid oxygen loading is now complete on
the second stage that means that Falcon
9 is now fully loaded with one million 1
million pounds of fuel and kerosene and
liquid oxygen and now we are clearing
out the liquid oxygen line on the
transfer director and that is why you
see those white clouds that are taking
over your screen there right now
and there you can see a better view of
the venting
next up will be Falcon 9 in startup
that's when the internal flight
computers will take over the launch
countdown
and that is at the T minus one minute
mark
Falcon innocent startup
good call out now we're just waiting for
the final call from the launch director
let's watch director on countdown one
hold hold hold
launch abort has started
now as you just heard the launch
director we have had a hold hold hold
hold on the countdown
and this launch director on countdown
net uh Emmanuel holds was called
to weather constraints
now as you heard on the Nets the launch
director did call a hold hold hold hold
on the countdown today and that was due
to weather we have been keeping an eye
out on that the vehicle and payload
remain in good health and our next
launch opportunity is tomorrow at the
same time at 11 48 PM Pacific time
as always thanks for watching and we
hope to see everyone back here for our
next attempt